hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast neural circuits important for
valence processing
I am Brenda Kelly Kim of laggards and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
this presentation has been approved for
a category 1 continuing medical
education credit by Loma Linda
University if you are interested in
obtaining CMI's after attending this
presentation please click on the get
your free CME credits button in the
bottom left corner of the event screen
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
laberd's and sponsored by Olympus
Olympus is a precision technology leader
who designs and delivers innovative
solutions in core business areas such as
medical and surgical products life
science imaging systems industrial
measurement and imaging instruments and
cameras and audio products their
products are used to capture images of
the world from the microscopic to the
panoramic for more information please
visit olympus america.com
we have a few announcements before we
begin this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of your presentation window or
submit your problem through the green
Q&A button lower left I would now like
to introduce today's speaker dr. Kate I
dr. Tighe began her education as an
undergraduate research assistant at MIT
from 1999 to 2003 she considered
continued her studies at the University
of California San Francisco as a
graduate student and Patricia janux lab
studying electrophysiological properties
of amygdala neurons both in vivo and
ex-vivo during reward seeking behavior
kay then did a short postdoc
Antonella bunchy now the intramural
director of NIDA to study synaptic
strength following reward learning
followed by a postdoc at Stanford
University with Karl Deisseroth where
she used novel optogenetic techniques to
detect the neural circuitry underlying
psychiatric disease kay is currently an
assistant professor at Massachusetts
Institute of Technology in the pick our
Institute for learning and memory a
member of the department of brain and
cognitive sciences she is also an NY SCF
neuroscience robertson investigator I'll
now turn it over to dr. kay for her
presentation hi so it's really exciting
to be giving this talk so my lab is
interested in the neural circuit
mechanisms underlying the valence
processing and by balance processing I
mean positive or negative valence so
motivation to seek rewards motivation to
avoid negative consequences and so in
our quest to understand the circuit
mechanisms underlying motivated
behaviors we first
so basically motivated bieber's
represent the foundation of our research
program we first need to understand what
those neural circuits are what are the
different cell types within that neural
circuit that contribute to different
aspects of either often there are cells
that do opposite things that are in the
same circuit and how can the balance of
excitatory or inhibitory synaptic input
influence the firing of those cells so
in some very broad strokes and I know
this is a simplification but I think
valence processing is a useful heuristic
so in terms of thinking about the the
normal healthy brain you can imagine
that the motivation to seek rewards and
the motivation to avoid potential
negative consequences is balanced
however one way of conceptualizing many
different psychiatric diseases is a
perturbation bayless processing so for
example an anxiety you might see too
much motivation to avoid potential
negative consequences in addiction the
off
too much motivation relative to
motivation to avoid negative process too
much motivation to seek rewards in the
environment and you can imagine that
actually given the amount of comorbidity
that exists between different classes of
psychiatric disease dates
perhaps there are neural circuit
perturbations that that can contribute
to multiple disease states and so I
think this is a different angle that's
important to take so today I'll be
talking about a few different insights
that has come from our research program
and some examples are that projections
from the same brain region can target
different downstream regions that then
mediate distinct behaviors and so this
helps us this is kind of a big step in
terms of recontextualizing the brain in
terms of functionality by region to
functionality within circuits also I'll
give examples of how different cells
even neighboring cells using the same
neuromodulatory systems can give rise to
distinct aspects of behavior also
different different components
excitatory inhibitory within the same
projection from one region to another
can any opposing rules on behavior so
for one example of this first type of
representation of ALS processing we have
sorry there's a little issue but okay so
one story I want to talk about today was
how different types of dopamine neurons
can represent different aspects of
social interaction so in terms of
seeking out social contact you can
imagine that both positive and negative
valence can contribute to the motivation
together social context so for example
social interactions can be in themselves
rewarding and in on the flip side of
that social isolation is known to be
aversive in fact solitary confinement is
one of the most severe punishments
available and chronic social isolation
has been used as it as an animal model
for neuropsychiatric disorders but even
perceive social isolation loneliness
can produce anxiety depression and
changes brain changes increased changes
in urinary catecholamines for example
and one thing that hasn't really been
explored up to this point is what are
the neural adaptation that occur with
acute social isolation so just to kind
of see where we are in the field right
now we know that from from recent
studies published just a few months ago
that phasic activation of ventral
tegmental area this is just a midbrain
region ventral tegmental area dopamine
neurons promote social interaction and
this is this is essentially a pro-social
effect so when we use CH r2 or
channelrhodopsin to basically activate
these VTA dopamine neurons using a
transgenic tyrosine hydroxylase cream
Mouse so this just allows us to
selectively expressed channelrhodopsin
in dopamine neurons or tyrosine
hydroxylase positive neurons and we can
compare this to a non viral control that
doesn't have any option so basically
what we find is that in channelrhodopsin
animals you see a pro-social effect and
so similarly using the same manipulation
expressing channelrhodopsin and
activating these neurons we can also see
that animals will know spoke perform an
operant behavior for example hooking
their nose in a little hole to receive
intracranial self stimulation of these
bt a dopamine neurons we also know that
these neurons promote place preference
so altogether pro-social positively
reinforcing promotes place preference
together this kind of paints picture to
the beach a dopamine neurons as being
consistent with social reward but what
about the other aspects so we know that
bt dopamine neurons are important for
social reward but what about the
aversive components associated with
social isolation so the story I'm about
to tell you is actually an unpublished
story led by a postdoctoral fellow in my
lab Jillian Mackey's and in
collaboration with Mark Wallace
so okay
there was such a thing as a cellular
substrate for loneliness then we would
expect the following characteristics one
that these neurons would be sensitive to
social isolation two that they might be
dependent on prior social environment
three that this is distinct from general
heightened anxiety states or that these
cells would drive it when activated a
pro-social effect however in contrast to
pto Menards they would be promoting an
aversive rather than an appetitive or
rewarding state okay so what do we know
we know that if we use this proxy for
glutamatergic synaptic strength called
AMPA to enemy ratio if we look at these
VTA dopamine neurons that have been
shown to be important for social reward
there's no difference when we socially
isolate animals so this is just a figure
indicating that when we take animals
that were housed in a group we just
record from VTA dopamine neurons there's
no change in synaptic strength when we
isolate animals for 24 hours there's
also no change in synaptic strength
however there's been recently you know
actually in in contrast to PD donors
which are very well studied there are
another population of dopamine neurons
in the dorsal raphe nucleus that have
been scarcely described but recently
they were very briefly described can we
have investigated them in some more gap
and so what we found is that when we
examine dorsal raphe nucleus or DRN
dopamine neurons what we see is that
after 24 hours of social isolation we
observe a robust change in amphetamine
ratio or synaptic strength so the
glutamatergic excitatory synaptic inputs
onto these neurons are increased after
acute social isolation but not any a new
caged novelty for example so um that's
the first characteristics said these
neurons show synaptic plasticity in
response to social isolation then again
the next the next component is what
about previous experience and so if we
examine animals that are housed in in
occasions with different numbers of
animals so with up to five or
or Cajun eights versus just one other
cage mate if we just sample from those
animals there's no relationship with
glutamatergic synaptic strength onto
these dorsal raphe dopamine neurons
however if we isolate these animals the
previous cage sighs is predictive so the
more animals that were in the cage prior
to isolation the greater the synaptic
potentiation okay so now we've shown
that this the degree of sensitivity is
dependent on prior social environments
so what about anxiety hmm when you
acutely isolate socially isolate an
animal they might experience some
anxiety obviously these these prey
animals have evolved to to exist in
groups and this could be offer safe
safety from predatory threats or or
energy homeostasis is a number of
different things so one thing we wanted
to investigate was whether anxiety could
be an issue so what we did was that we
did the same manipulation we isolated
these animals just prior to socially
isolating these animals in the same cage
we either provide administered either
vehicle just a vehicle control or
diazepam which is an anxiety drug that's
used in humans as well as animals and
what we found was essentially no change
so using an anti-anxiety drug did not
change the synaptic potentiation
furthermore when we used optogenetic
tools specifically channelrhodopsin-2
to activate to basically activate these
dorsal raphe nucleus dopamine neurons we
did not observe a change in classic
animal models for anxiety animal asses
for anxiety the elevated plus maze or
the open field test so it seems that
this cellular substrate is independent
of general anxiety speeds the next thing
is well
if it's true that the synaptic
potentiation that occurs following
social isolation is adapt it perhaps to
increase motivational Drive to seek
social contact then we would expect that
activating these neurons or increasing
activity in these neurons would have a
pro-social effect so we next tested that
and we performed a test where
essentially the animal can freely
explore this chamber so it's a three
chamber social sociability test and
under one cup there is a juvenile and
under the other cup there's nothing and
essentially what we're looking at is the
amount of preference relative to
baseline and so the animals can freely
explore and the light is on for the
whole illumination epoch independent of
where the animal explores and what we're
measuring is the amount that the animal
explore okay so this is gonna be
different from the next task that I show
you so what we see is that in animals
that are expressing channelrhodopsin in
their dorsal raphe nucleus dopamine
neurons we see a robust increase in
social preference so basic activation of
these neurons causes an increase in
social preference no effect in the
control okay and then so now I've shown
you that there's this pro-social effect
next we wanted to see if there was
indeed an aversive State so this is very
different from what we would expect from
BTA dopamine neurons another neighboring
region of dopamine neurons that where
you if you activate VTA dopamine neurons
for example you'll get strong preference
animals prefer animals find the photo
stimulation preferable and choose to be
on a side that's paired with photo
stimulation and so in this task
basically both sorry there's one more
tas before that so another task that
that i've already told you about that
beachy dopamine neurons are important
for is intracranial self stimulation
animals will work to get stimulation of
these neurons so we did not observe that
in dorsal raphe ee neurons so the next
thing we did was to see if we if animals
had placed preference as in VJ w neurons
so in this task what we do is we allow
animal to freely explore chamber however
one side of the chamber the light paired
side is is paired with stimulation so
illumination is only delivered to these
dorsal raphe dopamine neurons when the
animals on that side of the chamber
so--that's pair decided we
counterbalance across animals which side
is paired with illumination and what we
found was that animals that were
expressing channelrhodopsin versus
control animals animals that were
suppressing channelrhodopsin showed a
preference for the side that was not
paired so an aversion to the side was
paired of floor to stimulation so by
producing this place avoidance this is
reflecting an aversive state that's that
signaled by these mouths that's one
interpretation okay so to just put this
all together now we've shown these
features that might be consistent with
the negative valence aspect of a seeking
social context so how is it possible
that these dorsal raphe nucleus dopamine
neurons mediate this distinct aspect of
behavior from ventral tegmental area
dopamine neurons well one one
possibility is that they might recruit
different downstream targets since we
know that's important already from the
amygdala so what we did first was to
investigate if you know we actually was
were able to detect dopamine release in
downstream targets and what we found was
we injected channelrhodopsin fused to a
fluorescent protein he yfp into these
deer and dopamine neurons we could
observe expression of this protein in
axon terminals and so places where we
found that there was bright expression
included the bed nucleus of the stria
terminalis
the NS t in the central amygdala or
central central make us see a and these
two regions are often considered part of
the extended amygdala and so it's this
is the first time that we've been able
to detect dopamine transits then we use
a technique called fast and cyclic
voltammetry with
is an electrochemical technique that
allows us to detect sub-second
transients or dopamine release so what
we did was we optically stimulated in
the dorsal raphe nucleus and then picked
up dopamine release in the bed nucleus
of the street terminals as well as a
central amygdala so this is very
different from the downstream targets
that we would see for the for the
ventral tegmental area we also found
that these neurons are not just
releasing dopamine
it appeared that they're also cold
releasing glutamate because we were able
to detect excitatory postsynaptic
currents in neurons that were located in
a bed nucleus of the street terminals as
well as the central amygdala when
exciting axon terminals of these deer
and dopamine neurons so we also follow
this up to look using a big loop cream
so a marker for an animal that expresses
Cree in google rhetoric neurons and we
found that there was a substantial
co-localization of tyrosine hydroxylase
a marker for dopamine and glutamate and
i should mention that we know that these
are dopamine neurons rather than
norepinephrine because they don't
express gdh okay so essentially these
neurons kho-kho express glutamate but
not gaba - so just to summarize the
first part of this talk from reviewing
what we know about the VTA basically
from a number of very important studies
we know that bt neurons are potentiated
24 hours after administration of cocaine
as well as other drugs of abuse we know
that activating VTA dopamine neurons
promote social behavior that activating
Beiteinu Barracks supports positive
reinforcement and that the ventral
tegmental area
innervates other regions lutein olympic
system including the nucleus accumbens
or ventral striatum the medial
prefrontal cortex and the basal lateral
amygdala in contrast our study shows
that the dorsal raphe nucleus dopamine
neurons
our potentiated after 24 hours of social
isolation and activation of these
neurons also promote social behavior
however the activation of these neurons
produces negative reinforcement in
contrast the VTA and this can be
explained on a circuit level because the
dorsal raphe dopamine neurons innervate
different downstream targets including
the bed and visitors treated terminalis
and the central amygdala okay so that
was just one example hope and I should
also say this was this project was led
by Jillian Matthews a very talented
postdoc in my lab in collaboration with
Margolis so I've given you now an
example of how different cells using
that a different dopamine neurons can
give rise to distinct aspects of social
behavior and now I'll give you a
different example where components
within the same production can mediate
opposing roles so what do I mean by that
so this is essentially I'm just gonna
review a recent publication that we had
in the journal Cell and essentially uh
what we know about this is that this is
a totally different story but
essentially one of the earliest regions
that we know about intracranial flow
stimulation at all it's actually the
lateral hypothalamus and so this these
were some seminal studies identifying
that there were regions in the brain
that the animals were robustly respond
for to receive electrical stimulation so
lateral hypothalamic neurons are linked
to a variety of behaviors including
feeding homeostasis reward and early
recordings in the lateral hypothalamus
showed a relationship between satiety
state whether animals were hungry or
sated they would only show responses to
cues linked to be cues associated with
with appetitive rewards when they were
hungry not when they were seated and
then in a in other studies where
researchers electrically stimulated
different
regions of the lateral hypothalamus
there actually were very very
heterogeneous behaviors elicited and so
I know it's very small but basically all
these different points shell sites of
electrical stimulation that yielded
ejaculation bay stimulation biting of
pedal edges grooming or seizures and so
you can you can see that there was
obviously a lot of heterogeneity in this
region and so it's been a bit of a
puzzle to figure out for from systems
neuroscience perspective so the lateral
hypothalamus is interconnected with many
many different brain regions this could
be wives so heterogeneous the LH
receives input from many many different
regions including ventral tegmental area
dopamine neurons and also sends output
to many different regions including
ventral tegmental dopamine and so more
recently we found that these lateral
hypothermic neurons actually provide
monosynaptic so direct input on T V J
dopamine we also know that V J dopamine
neurons might be best known for their
encoding of reward prediction error
so essentially hmm if an unexpected
reward is delivered this is basically a
pair of event master histogram just
showing that each of these dots on the
plots on the on the right side of my
slide indicate a action potential and
then each row and to keep the trial and
then the histogram at the top is just in
showing the pool pooling of all that
data so basically in the first and the
top pair met master histogram what we're
looking at is a reward deliver that's
unexpected and you can see that bTW a
double neurons fire robustly up to an
unexpected reward if an animal in this
case it's a monkey is trained over many
many many many many trials that a
conditioned stimulus in this case I
believe it was a visual stimulus a
conditioned stimulus tone auditory
visual fitness whatever some neutral cue
is a very reliable predictor of the
reward then you'll see over many many
trials if it's always beep juice beet
juice beet juice then after a while
whenever this condition stimulus is
presented
you'll see robust aphasic activation in
response to the predictive stimulus
rather than the reward no response to
the rewards the reward is expected and
so that's the idea of this prediction so
in the case that a commission stimulus
was a reliable predictor of reward and
then suddenly that reward is
unexpectedly omitted this is a case of
reward prediction error and then because
a reward was expected but omitted then
that these dopamine arts actually show a
decrease in firing when the reward was a
minute so that's the third pretty much
history okay so fast-forward to more
recent times and just a couple of years
ago it was shown that using optogenetics
if you activate or sorry if you express
channelrhodopsin in lateral hip olymic
neurons and then photo stimulate axon
terminals in the ventral tegmental area
you'll get again robust positive
reinforcement animals will respond and
open up their nose or press the lever to
to perform intracranial cell stimulation
and this study proposed as was commonly
thought that this was mediated by the
glutamatergic component of the lateral
hydrophobic projection to the ventral
tegmental area LH tbta so one issue with
optogenetic manipulations in general is
that particularly activation is that the
activation that we deliver is not
physiological we're just delivering some
some parameters of our choosing and
oftentimes this is this is not really
how the brain works at least that much
synchrony right so what we wanted to
know is what LH neurons that projected
the ventral tegmental area are doing
naturally how are they transmitting
information what information is being
transmitted from the lateral at the
thalamus chewing the ventral tegmental
area and i should also remind you that
about LH is more been linked to
homeostasis and and feeding the ventral
tegmental area of more linked to reward
and reward seeking behaviors or reward
prediction error and so we wanted to
investigate this question so to do this
we used
a novel viral approach using a
combination of an anterograde Lee
travelling virus that went that infected
neurons in the LH and a retro really
traveling virus traveling backwards from
from the VTA so in this entire greatly
traveling virus we expressed a Cree
dependent channelrhodopsin so channel
drops and that only be expressed in the
presence of clear economies and then
into the ventral tegmental area we
injected a viral vector carrying career
comedies so only in neurons originating
in the lateral hypothalamus and
terminating in the ventral tegmental
area would we actually see recombination
and therefore opsin expression so first
we want to make sure that this will work
and we record it from neurons in the
lateral hypothalamus that expressed
channelrhodopsin and they fired very
robustly at Layton sees of three to
eight milliseconds which is important in
terms of characterizing how how ups and
functions in this brain region
interestingly if you patch if we
recorded from neurons that were directly
adjacent to these channelrhodopsin
expressing neurons we actually did not
see any activity so that was actually a
little bit of a surprise I would expect
to see some sort of network activity
this allowed us to take this information
in vivo so when we record in vivo or
essentially implanting an opt road so an
optical fiber surrounded by recording
electrodes and this allows us to record
the natural activity of these neurons
and then at the end of the behavioral
task we can shine light and see which
neurons are expressing channelrhodopsin
and therefore which lateral hip lemak
neurons are actually projecting to the
ventral tegmental area so before I tell
you what they did during the behavior I
have to tell you about what we found in
terms of these populations so
essentially we looked the latency
between the illumination pulse onset and
the firing pattern and as we expected as
you can see in this frequency
distribution histogram these green or
type 1 neurons are essentially neurons
that
our firing between three and eight it's
exactly the distribution we got
completely consistent with what we
observed when we patch on the cells so
when we patch themselves we have a lot
of confidence we can see exactly what
we're doing when we're recording in vivo
explained we don't exactly know so we
have to validate that approach what we
found in vivo that we weren't expecting
to see was another population of neurons
that showed a much longer photo response
latency so neurons that spiked or had
action potentials in response to light
that were much much longer on the order
of a hundred milliseconds and so this
was puzzling because this is this is not
consistent with channelrhodopsin
expression likely to be involving some
sort of circuit feedback so again this
is just an example of this type one
neuron we either can we deliver
illumination in a bunch of different
parameters here I'm just showing you one
Hertz pulses of five millisecond pulse
widths and on the left and then on the
right a one-second continuous pulse of
light and you can see the response of
these neurons that are expressing
channelrhodopsin consistent with what we
expect we also again found this puzzling
type two population of neurons that
showed this really slow delayed but yet
reliably time-locked responses to light
so we had a few ideas of what could be
going on one possibility was hmm that
since we know that the LH and the VTA
the lateral poblanos and
ventral tegmental area had these
reciprocal connections we thought okay
it could be a circuit feedback loop
however it's also possible given how
many regions the lateral hypothalamus is
connected with that it could be
collaterals that are being expressed
from these channelrhodopsin expressing
neurons that are activating some
intermediate region and then thereby
activating these these type two neurons
and or it could be a mixture of these
two possibilities and in these circuit
diagrams
you're obviously simplified and not
meant to be you know anatomically
accurate or anything like that these
dotted lines just indicate that we don't
know if it's a direct or indirect
circuit component like in terms of
faulty synaptic versus monosynaptic okay
so to differentiate between these two
possibilities essentially these neurons
downstream of the VTA is that what's
going on the way we tested this
hypothesis was we use the same
expression strategy I just described to
express channelrhodopsin the two
polarizing excitatory Thompson in
lateral hypothermic grounds that
predicted the VTA we also expressed an
inhibitory opsin on Mara an option that
hyperpolarizes cell membranes when we
illuminate with yellow light onto into
the VTA so we did three epochs of photo
photo manipulation and the first epoch
we just activated LH T DT neurons and
the second epoch we also were still
activating them but we we now are
inhibiting the ventral tegmental area
with halorhodopsin and then the third
epoch is just like the first epoch just
to see if it all recovers so this is
something that you obviously wouldn't be
able to do with pharmacology he also did
the same experiment with toyota toxin so
what we found was that type 1 neurons
unaffected by VTA inhibition which makes
sense if they're expressing
channelrhodopsin obviously wouldn't make
any difference if we inhibit a
downstream region two neurons in
contrast almost all the neurons showed a
complete attenuation of the light
response when we shut down the VTA we
also did this experiment tetrodotoxin
and observed complete shutdown of all of
all photo responses with with shorter
toxin so in these type two neurons we
know that they're essentially downstream
of the VTA so it supports this circuit
model okay so now that I've told you
what these different types of neurons
are I can finally tell you about what
they do during behavior and why am I
telling you all this I wouldn't tell you
this if it wasn't really cool okay so
first we didn't really know what to
expect so we thought we would start with
a simple reward task in this reward task
animals are trained to stick their nose
in this nose book response up random
where a bean break
detect a nose poke and 50% of beam
brakes are going to be paired with a cue
a conditioned stimulus followed by
sucrose delivery in an adjacent port and
50% of nose books are not paired with
anything and this is for us to be able
to differentiate the motor response from
the neural response to the conditioned
stimulus only after this behavioral task
do we do the photo tagging that I just
told you about okay so essentially what
we found was that LHC VTA neurons type 1
neurons encode primarily port entry
whereas type 2 neurons these neurons
that are downstream of the VTA encode
the conditioned stimulus so this is just
showing you all the neurons that we
recorded and essentially the different
breakdowns so surprisingly it was very
homogeneous of all the type 1 neurons
that did anything relevant to the task
they all encoded for entry one of them
also encoded the key type to neurons was
more heterogeneous these Venn diagrams
just indicate that some type 2 neurons
only encoded the conditioned stimulus
others only include the port and some
encoded boat on so here is just an
example of how much we can learn from
this technique so I know this is a kind
of a complicated diagram but basically
this just breaks down all the possible
categories of responses we might expect
and on the bottom these unlabeled
neurons are just unknown so they this is
kind of what we would get if we were
performing a traditional
electrophysiological study you're gonna
get a heterogeneous set of responses
however if you look at the type 1
responses versus of type 2 responses
you'll notice that there are very
distinct response profiles I think this
is what the power is of using our
ability to overlay anatomical
information about the circuit with
circuit function and you can see that
some at least some of the heterogeneity
that we observe in lateral and girls in
general can be explained by where they
are in the circuit whether they're up or
downstream of the ventral tegmental area
for example that's just one one aspect
of a mini ok so what we found again was
that these type 1 neurons
encode poor what does that mean
encoding sucrose is according action of
reward seeking well to test this what we
did was in a subset of rewarded trials
and these animals are very well trained
so when they're when they are presented
with the conditioned stimulus they
really expect reward to be delivered in
a small subset of trials we omitted
unexpectedly omitted the sucrose reward
however this did not affect very you
know this did not affect the neural
response to poor entry this suggests
that type one neurons are actually
encoding the action of reward seeking
rather than the receipt a reward which
screws consumption or anything like that
so again they're responding regardless
of the presence of sucrose telling us
it's not the presence of sugars what
they're responding to we also wanted to
investigate if this was if maybe these
neurons were encoding a conditioned
response to learn action of reward
seeking or if they're just encoding you
know motor responses or general
motivated behaviors so we looked at what
would happen if we presented sucrose in
the port and the animals were treated it
prior to training hired I mean sort of
you know pairing of a predictive cue and
what we found actually to my surprise is
that prior to training animals will
enter the port get the sucrose but they
will these LH neurons that projected the
VTA these type 1 neurons do not respond
to port entry and supers receipt
prior to any sort of training so it
really is only after the animals have
learned this action outcome relationship
or this perhaps condition stimulus
action a relationship that you observe
this this encoding property so only
after training GC response regardless of
the presence or absence of sucrose so
from this we can conclude these type 1
neurons encode the conditioned response
ok
in contrast type two neurons encode very
similar to a drug like mental area
dopamine neurons reward prediction error
we know that because these had two
neurons respond to unpredicted delivery
of sucrose and also are sensitive to the
unexpected omission of
reward so when we omit sucrose we see a
subsequent inhibition that is associated
with this this reward prediction error
like phenomena okay so this is just
summarizing what I just told you but
essentially this kind of comes to this
theory year this this this concept from
the drug addiction literature where
actions repeated many times can become
habits and habits are essentially what
lead compulsive behavior so if it's true
that these LH to beat a neurons are type
1 neurons encode the Lorne action
condition spawns or habit a reward
seeking then we should be able to
produce compulsive behavior by driving
this projection that was our hypothesis
so a little bit of formatting public my
slide I apologize for that essentially
what we did here was we express
channelrhodopsin in this projection
model at the bottom of the VTA and we
devised a separate task in this task
animals had to cross a shot grid to
retrieve sucrose so there's three epochs
first we train the animals to just
perform a Pavlovian conditioning
collect sucrose when a cue is presented
then we turn on a very mild but kind of
constant ongoing shock and this is
pretty aversive and this will reduce the
amount of responding these animals do
then in the third epoch we keep the
shock grid on but also turn on the light
and activate and drive this this
projection from the LGBTA and what we
found was that in again shock definitely
reduces the amount of responding that we
get but what we see is an increase in
sucrose seeking in the face of a
negative consequence which is kind of
the operational definition of compulsive
sucrose seeking when we activate the
lateral hemic to DJ pathway and so again
the operational definition of compulsive
reward seeking involves seeking the roar
of reward the traits of a negative
consequence seeking the reward when it's
not available and we also looked at that
as well extinction resistance and we
also found a tray
consistent in the same direction but our
most robust result was that we see that
these animals will seek sucrose in the
face of food shock more when we activate
this this production so we also want to
do the opposite experiment which is to
inhibit the LH to bt a projection using
halorhodopsin
so we did the same manipulation and we
actually found again the opposite was
thought so when we shut down this
pathway we actually saw that in the face
of shock animals worked well seek
sucrose even less than baseline so this
is exciting is it show that there's
bi-directional control of compulsive
sucrose seeking with this projection
however one thing that's very important
to think about that's very different
from in you know for food addiction or
sugar addiction relative to drug
addiction is that when we think about
natural rewards like food you could
argue that actually we need these things
we don't need drugs to survive so that's
that's a completely different category
and we're not worried about shutting
down the motivation to seek drugs
because we don't really don't need them
however food and and other appetitive
rewards could be important so we don't
want to mess with hunger driven pd that
is something that is very critical to
survival so we want to be careful about
that
so we next investigated what happens
when we take animals and just allow them
to feed freely in an unrestricted manner
without without any negative consequence
and this is not sugar this is just
regular food that they get every day so
in the first experiment we looked at
what happened in sated vice so since
these animals already showed compulsive
increased compulsive succour seeking
when we activated this pathway we want
to see what happened if if we drove this
pathway an animal that was full really
fed but as eating as much because they
want and then they're just placed in the
cage with food so at baseline they spend
a very little time feeding because
they're full and then when we activate
this production robust
increase in feeding um then we did a
different experiment so because we saw a
reduction in compulsive sucrose seeking
we wanted to actually food restrict
these animals to see
inhibiting the LH DBT a pathway would
further reduce feeding hunger different
feeding and so what we found was
actually no even though we see a
reduction in compulsive super seeking we
don't see a reduction in hunger driven
feeding and we inhibit this pathway so
that's exciting
it suggests that circuits that are
important for compulsive feeding and and
hunger different feeding are separate
and that raises the possibility that we
could target this pathway and
selectively shut down compulsive feeding
but not mess with hunger trigger feeding
or adaptive to me okay so so sorry I
need to pick it up a little bit so
basically in a nutshell what we found
was that a lot of lamech neurons as
expected
do you provide glutamatergic input onto
bt do Bernard's as as previously
proposed but we also see GABAergic input
directly on to these bt a dopamine that
are you know important for driving
reward motivation we also saw that there
was a mixture of both glutamatergic and
GABAergic excitatory and inhibitory
input mama synaptically on to be ta
Gavin's and we basically explore this
using general rhodopsin assisted circuit
mapping so essentially it's kind of a
hodge podge and that was surprising we
didn't expect the GABAergic component
would represent such a substantial
component of the projection so our next
experiment was to use transgenic mouse
lines that allowed us to selectively
target only the glutamatergic or gab or
two components of the LHD BGA pathway
when we targeted the glutamatergic
component of the LH DDT a pathway and
activated this pathway we actually found
anything a reduction in seeding although
this was too close to Florida to be
statistically significant and in
contrast contrary to what we expected it
was the GABAergic component that
robustly drove feeding
so just to summarize what I've told you
what we found in the study LHC beauty
neurons encode reward seeking actions
after they transition to habits not
before learning is occurring a subset of
these LH neurons that are downstream in
the pga show reward prediction error
like properties we also I also showed
you that activating lht VTA projections
increases compulsive sucrose seeking
while inhibiting this production reduces
compulsive super seeking but without
altering hunger trip and feeding and
that the GABAergic component of the VTA
drives feeding related behaviors while
we proposed that the glutamatergic
component actually plays a more
regulatory role and what I didn't have
time to show you yet unpublished data is
that the GABAergic component supports
positive reinforcement while the
glutamatergic component supports
negative means okay so just to wrap up
what I've told you today I've just given
you a couple of you know vignettes or
snapshots of different different
representations in the brain of how
valence can be processed and how
behaviors like social social behavior or
feeding behavior can be driven by both
positive and negative valence components
okay so to make sure I have time for
questions I just want to move forward
and acknowledge all my funding sources
and the people who did the work in the
lab so the cell paper and the follow-up
studies were led by Edward Nia a
graduate student in my lab and he also
had a lot of help from Gillian Matthews
who did all the ex vivo told cell
patch-clamp recordings for that study as
well as Steven Alsop who worked very
hard and spearheaded the compulsion
behavioral studies Gillian Matthews also
was the sole lead author on well yeah
but the lead person on the project that
I told you about that's still
unpublished about social isolation and
this again was conducted in
collaboration with mark convalesce okay
so that's it for me and I'll just
I'll just thank you for your attention
and answer any questions thank you dr.
Tighe for that informative presentation
before we get started on the
question-and-answer session I'd like to
remind our audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can and I see
our first question is LH VTA type one
neurons activated response is it the
main component for addictions so that's
that's a great question um we don't we
don't know the answer to that yet I mean
certainly I think it's possible that it
is a component I would be I would
predict that it is the similar circuitry
that's involved in in other types of
addictions drug addiction other types of
addictions but we don't know we haven't
directly tested that we just discovered
this this circuit component very
recently thank you our next question
does the lesioning of the ventral medial
nucleus of the hypothalamus leading to
the fat rat syndrome linked to G ABA
it's a good question too we actually
don't know how oh sorry I so that's also
an excellent question
we haven't directly tested that
hypothesis we we I guess I would
speculate that there are many parallel
circuits that are involved in feeding
and my colleagues at many different
places including Scott Stearns in for
example and have done a lot of work in
these other hypokalemic regions showing
that there'll there's a lot of
redundancy which makes sense in
behaviors that are so critical to
survival like feeding I think it makes
sense that there's going to be a lot of
redundancy and a lot of different
different aspects
that can be modulated independently so
this is just this is just one example
that shows it's very specific to
compulsive to compulsive feeding rather
than hundreds of competing so I don't
know the answers your posturing yet but
that's a great question
thank you you have another question
what does today's discussion and your
findings mean to social and workplace
motivation in general so I'm not sure
how to answer that question I'm maybe
I'm not sure I completely understand
that question but I guess I would say
that you know it makes sense that there
are there are multiple motivational
drives and in every behavior and I think
if we instead of just kind of saying oh
this is this is you know some behavior
that you elicit there are many different
types of motivation I could drive that
so positive or negative so fear driven
aversive driven or reward based I'm not
sure I understand the question okay
thank you dr. Tighe I'm afraid we are
out of time I don't see any more
questions thank you very much for that
informative presentation I want to thank
our audience for their interesting
questions and participation in today's
event and I would like to thank our
sponsor Olympus and of course our
speaker dr. ty today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
March 2016 you'll receive an email from
lab rats alerting you when this webcast
will be available for replay we invite
you to forward that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event thank you very much bye